The most important job I ever saw myself having one day was being a dad.
It's the most rewarding thing in the planet, to see him learn something from me.
It's important to pass on those little bits of knowledge that help you...
...maybe stand out just a bit more,...
...sharing those little father-son moments.
Those memories and that platform through my father of like, being well-groomed,...
...having great style and that's kinda always stuck with me as I've gotten older.
My son is 15 months old.
I think I would just make sure...
...that he knows how important keeping himself looking presentable,...
...even if it's in a sort of messy way, do you know what I mean?
It's good to be organized, put-together,...
...and I think that that goes into, in the way you're groomed.